Oh je suis juste sur votre chibre là.
Non ça fait rien, ça glisse, ça va aller.
Chaque fois que je bois
de l'eau je suis ivre.
C'est une maladie.
Vous avez tapé tellement fort,
que vous avez reculé,
vous êtes tombé.
Non mais un truc incroyable!
C'est trop la honte déjà.
Bah c'est la honte après...
Ça va...
Ouais c'est un peu la honte quand même.
Mettez vous sur le côté.
C'est bizarre que vous soyez pas debout.
Vous êtes allongés.
Vous avez un problème de vision?
Non je suis en HD 720p.
C'est le soleil dans la gueule ça.
Trop de soleil à Marseille.
*Musique Hip-Hop*
Vous avez pas vu la vitre monsieur?
Ça va?
Bonjour Papa.
Respirez un ptit peu.
Tu arrives à se lever?
La Tour Eiffel c'est par où?
Ah je crois que vous êtes
pas dans la bonne ville là.
Ah.
Je voulais attraper Donkey Kong et il est devant.
C'est un copain?
Donkey Kong?
Je connais pas.
Ouais c'est un pote à moi ouais.
C'est un pote...
Vous voulez pas me chanter une petite chanson?
*À la claire fontaine m'en allant promener...*
Non non non c'est pire,
en fait c'est pire.
Vous êtes marseillaise?
Ouais.
Ils sont très gentils les marseillais.
L'entraide des marseillais...
Franchement...
J'espère qu'on fera au moins
300 000 vues avec cette merde.
Qu'est ce qui t'arrives?
Qu'est ce que t'as fait?
Quoi?
Il faut pas m'engueuler, j'ai pas... j'ai...
Je souffre mais tout le monde s'en branle.
L'autre con là.
Il passe devant il l'aide pas.
Qu'est ce qu'il vous ai arrivé monsieur?
À vrai dire je me suis dépucelé hier,
et depuis je suis tout zazimute.
Mais c'est pas grave ça ira mieux.
Qu'est ce que vous faites tous dans mon bain?
Vous n'êtes pas dans le bain monsieur.
Ah putain!
Et comment vous vous appelez?
Sylvie.
Sylvie comment?
Sylvie Jolie.
Viens, viens.
Hey tu t'appelles pas Sylvie Jolie.
La semaine dernière j'ai vu un mec,
il s'est pris un poteau imaginaire.
Encore plus con que moi.
Ça va?
Oh je me suis pris le panneau en pleine gueule.
Quel panneau?
Je trouve quand même que c'est une drôle d'idée
de mettre des panneaux partout.
Non mais il n'y a pas de panneau là.
Si.
Là juste là.
Il y en a un ?
Ouais il est là.
Voilà.
Vous allez où là?
Là je vais marcher un petit peu.
Vous savez vers la gare.
Je pense que je vais aller à la gare.
Je vais y aller en Moonwalk.
*Musique Hip-Hop style 80's*
J'étais en train de faire un Moonwalk et...
Bah oui en a vu.
Vous vous êtes pris direct le panneau.
Il était bien le Moonwalk?
Hein ?
Parce que je le travaille en ce moment.
C'est pas trop ça hein.
C'est pas ça?
Et non.
Merde!
Vous savez le faire le Moonwalk?
Ah nan pas du tout.
Par contre vous savez le critiquer.
Hein?
*Musique  "La Marseillaise" (instrumentale)*
Ça pue la merde.
Je suis allongé dans la merde.
Je suis tombé dans la merde.
*Musique classique style "pizzicato"*